hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I am
going to explain a 2013 American Comedy
and fantasy movie called RIPD Nick
Walker is a detective from the Boston
Police Department he buries a gold
artifact that he stole from a drug
dealer during a drug bust under an
orange tree in his backyard the next day
Nick goes to work as usual while his
wife Julia starts her day with jogging
along the road at the office Nick talks
to his partner Bobby about his intention
to turn the gold in as evidence however
Bobby who also has the gold in his
possession disagrees with the idea
saying that they could earn a lot of
money from the gold as Bobby is almost
convinced to turn in his gold too their
boss suddenly comes in and gives them
another drug bust Mission they
immediately drive over to the crime
scene and with the help of a group of
police they break into the abandoned
building turns out that the gangsters
have been waiting for them and the
gunfight ensues Nick spots the drug
dealer attempting to chase him to the
top of the building suddenly bobby shows
up telling Nick that he's not going to
turn in his gold as a result he shoots
Nick who eventually dies afterwards Nick
wakes up discovering that time around
him has stopped he walks out of the
building and then gets drawn into the
mysterious Vortex Nick ends up in an
office where a woman named Proctor
offers him a job in our ipd or Rest in
Peace Department because he used to be a
skillful police officer Nick initially
thinks that it's just a joke but she
then explains that he's dead and soon
will be sent to judgment so she gives
him a chance to return to Boston for the
last time while working for ritd to
capture dead people who have managed to
escape judgment called deados Nick
agrees to the offer and officially
becomes a RIPD officer proof by RIPD
tattoo on his chest on his first day in
the office Proctor brings him to ripped
HQ where he learns the deados or dead
people are now looking like Monsters
instead of human beings she then
introduces him to Roy and ex-martial in
the 1800s who will become his partner in
RIPD they use the toilet as a portal
that transfers them to Earth since it's
his first day Roy takes Nick to his own
funeral where he attempts to talk to
Julia but she doesn't tea right
recognize him Nick also tries to attack
Bobby there after that Roy reveals that
Nick s given a new body and must accept
his new identity which makes him look
like an old Chinese Grandpa while his
partner is granted a model body on their
way Roy reminds his partner to forget
his past and focus on his task as RIPD
officer because chasing Julia will be a
waste of time in the evening they go to
an apartment to haunted detto Roy gives
Nick Special bullets which are used to
kill debos and must be shot in the head
they eventually arrive at dead OS room
the detto still looks like a normal
human being so the RIPD officers provoke
him until he transforms into a
terrifying ghetto monster at first detto
is not as aggressive as he looks as Nick
begins to Cuff his hands he becomes
enraged and wreaks havoc on the entire
room he eventually jumps off the window
so do the officers because they're
already dead they are not injured at all
and are finally able to Corner the detto
just before Roy shoots the detto he
vomits some bold artifacts which are
similar to the ones Nick stole before
Nick becomes curious about the gold
artifacts but his partner keeps babbling
about his performance which makes Nick
mad and then throws him to a bus causing
him to lose his beloved hat as they
return to the ripped HQ Nick tells his
partner that the data was trying very
hard to protect the goal from them but
Roy thinks that it's just a useless and
cheap gold then turns it to another
officer because Nick keeps insisting to
find out about the gold they attend a
baseball match to meet with Roy s
informant Elliott Nick asks the
informant about the gold but he also
claims that it s worthless and means
nothing to them not satisfied with the
answer Nick gives him the gold and
secretly observes Nick s movement from a
distance as expected Elliot arranges a
meeting with a man who turns out to be
Bobby Nick s ex-partner and subsequently
hands him the gold they follow Bobby
from behind who eventually stops by at
Nick's house Nick sneaks into the house
and eavesdrops on his conversation with
Julia Nick is confused when finding out
that his ex-partner is asking about Nick
s gold Julia and Bobby go to the
backyard where the man retrieves the
gold buried under the orange tree Julia
is very upset after knowing that his
husband was a thief the pair Then
followed Bobby to a building where they
see Bobby hand over the gold to adetto
named Pulaski afterwards they
immediately confront the dedo lock him
inside a freezer and then interrogate
him since he refuses to talk Nick baits
him with a special powder he consumes
the powder and transforms into a giant
monster Pulaski escapes with his
horrifying body shape attracting nearby
public attention Roy attempts to capture
the data with his weapon but he's not
strong enough causing him to be pulled
away by the monster after a long chase a
lot of destroyed cars numerous bullets
wasted Pulaski finally gets cornered
inside a building so he decides to flee
through the Elevator Shaft Nick tries to
block him with the elevator but fails
returning to the HQ Proctor seems upset
because they let an exposed Dettol loose
on the street but she also has good news
for them she reveals that the gold are
actually part of a dangerous artifact
known as the staff of Jericho she warns
them that if all the pieces are put
together a big Vortex will be created
which allows the dead people to come
back to earth the bad news is Roy and
Nick are suspended and most likely will
be erased entirely from the world
because of their failure to capture a
detto since tomorrow might be his last
day Nick returns to earth and confronts
Julia in the jogging track he tries to
convince his wife that he's Nick but she
doesn't believe him is all she sees is
an old Chinese man Roy appears and tells
his partner to focus on the job but Nick
makes it clear that there is nothing he
can do Roy begins to babble again until
Nick finally realizes that he must fight
for one last time or Adele be a total
Destruction for Earth Nick grows
suspicious of Bobby assuming that he's
also a dedo but still hasn't got any
evidence about it on the other hand
Bobby meets with another detto he gives
him an artifact telling him to distract
the RIPD with it in the morning Nick and
Roy arrive at Bobby's house planning to
arrest him but Bobby S prepared for them
he welcomes Roy and allows him to enter
the house while Nick sneaks in from the
back door catching him off guard he
threatens him with the gun ordering
Bobby to take off the artifact on his
wrist as Bobby throws the medal away the
House suddenly Alters into a
half-destroyed building Bobby is then
arrested and Roy seizes the remaining
gold they bring Bobby to ripped HQ where
they confiscate all the stuff belonging
to Bobby unfortunately one of them is an
artifact that can freeze time when it
meets the other part of the artifact it
explodes and slows down all the officers
movement except the debos the dead
people use this opportunity to steal all
the gold from the HQ as the time goes
back to normal the debos have managed to
escape to Earth the dead house climb to
the top of the Commonwealth building and
immediately begin reassembling the staff
of Jericho upon arrival on Earth Roy
Nick and the others have to fight their
way to the building as the debos have
been waiting for for them Roy who used
to be a skillful Cowboy shows off his
shooting ability eliminating all the
deados in front of him shortly after the
buildings in Boston begin to collapse
while the detectives Drive their way to
the building meanwhile Julia is picked
up by Bobby S henchman because they plan
to have lunch together earlier just
after Julia arrives at the building
Bobby Reveals His true identity to her
which shocks the woman back to the
detectives they are confronted by
Pulaski but they just hit him with the
car crash him into the nearby building
then shoot him moments later the staff
is fully assembled and a Vortex is
formed Roy and Nick appear to rescue
Julia but Bobby stabs her first and then
uses her blood to power up the staff
because of that the dead Souls begin to
rain down the detectives fight all the
deados and manage to defeat all of them
since it asked Bobby remaining they
decide to split up Roy attempts to
destroy the staff while Nick distracts
Bobby as Nick is getting beaten up
repeatedly Roy pulls down a vehicle
which destroys the artifact completely
The Vortex eventually disappears and
Nick shoots Bobby in the head erasing
him entirely from the world on the verge
of death Julia finally can see Nick s
real face and body he apologizes then
begs Julia to move on with her life
she suddenly wakes up in a hospital
where Proctor disguises herself as a
doctor to ensure that Julia is okay as a
result of their heroic actions Nick has
been let off with a warning while Roy
has to extend his service at RIPD for
another 53 years additionally she also
gives him back his beloved hat before
they both depart Roy gives Nick a new
identity he's relieved but until he
finds out that he now appears as a Girl
Scout with orthodontic headgear on
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]